hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast microbiology x' role in
sepsis core measures presented by dr.
Donna Rourke a system director for
clinical and molecular microbiology at
Geisinger
I'm Cindy Valdez of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by BV diagnostic
systems BD is a global medical
technology company that is advancing the
world of health by improving medical
discovery diagnostics and the delivery
of care BD leads its patient and health
care workers safety and the technologies
that enable medical research and
clinical laboratories before we begin
I'd like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on the green
Q&A button located at the lower left of
the presentation window and type your
questions into the box that appear on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of this presentation also please notice
that you'll be viewing this presentation
in the slide window to enlarge that
window just click on the screen icon
located at the lower right if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation click on the support button
at the top right or use the Q&A button
and let us know you're having that
problem good news
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
click on the button in the bottom left
hand corner and follow the process for
obtaining your credits I'd now like to
introduce our presenter dr. Donna Wilk
dr. Wilke is a system director for
clinical and molecular microbiology at
Geisinger an integrated delivery system
in Pennsylvania as a diplomat of the
American Board of Medical Microbiology
dr. wilkes professional practice extends
to the national and international level
supporting initiatives in clinical and
molecular microbiology and Laboratory
leadership active in the American
Society of microbiology among
she is most well known for her strategic
thinking and predications
about new technology and its impact to
patient care as well as her work as one
of seven founding members of CDC ASM
collaboration of evidence-based
laboratory medicine best practices dr.
Wilke was selected as a clinical
research scholar at the University of
Arizona and in 2012 she received the
1885 distinguished scholar award which
acknowledges outstanding faculty whose
research scholarship and creative
contributions exemplify innovation
service and success in their respective
disciplines she is a 2016 award Laurette
selected by the American Society of
microbiology to receive the Biddy award
for clinical research and microbiology
please join me in welcoming dr. Donna
Wolk welcome dr. up Thank You Suzy
thanks so much so depending on where
where you are in the world good morning
good afternoon or good evening and of
course happy world sepsis day to all of
you on the line the objectives today
would be to introduce the concepts of
core measures for sepsis and their
impact on hospitals review some ways
that microbiology can support efforts to
improve those core measures and and
hopefully then downstream such as
outcomes give examples of blood culture
metrics and how they can support their
organization's sepsis program and review
some simple statistics that support
laboratory quality initiatives for blood
culture processes as was as Suzy
mentioned in the intro my perspective is
a regional core laboratory within a
larger integrated delivery network that
that aspires to accountable care
organization premises and this is a
picture of our core laboratory so we
cover four states with our health plan
and hospitals and clinics within central
Pennsylvania and although my
perspectives may be this large
integrated delivery network I have
worked in community-based hospitals
reference laboratories government
healthcare facilities and academic
medical centers in my career so I am
most most happy to field questions from
every level of healthcare organization
that's on the line
223 of you today by the way just FYI now
we'll start out with introducing the
concepts of core measures for sepsis and
their impact on hospitals the core
measures began in 1999 when the Centers
for Medicaid Medicare Services and the
Joint Commission began gathering
information which then led to the first
issuance of core measures these core
measures or quality measures and they
are in fact federal regulations that are
enacted under the Department of Health
and Human Services core measure
performance is based on adherence to the
metrics that are set and they are a part
of the ongoing Joint Commission
accreditation process when your hospital
gets inspected by gjc
satisfactory compliance is often greater
than or equal to 96 percent and this is
a publicly reported metric now the early
management bundle for severe sepsis and
septic shock were the step 1 in October
2015 when CMS and TJC launched the SEP 1
measure for all Joint Commission
accredited US hospitals and that's
around 4,000 of us the aim was to
improve outcomes for sepsis for example
reducing mortality by mandating
adherence to the CMS processes in the
step 1 bundle so step 1 is the first
core measure and bylaw still is the only
national quality measure for the early
management of sepsis and severe sepsis
it is by far the most complicated core
measure there are around 140 points of
adherence and if you don't hit them all
you lose adherence points very quickly
the evidence-based
process and quality measure is the one
delivered by CMS for the CMS defined
sepsis bundle but these measures for the
SEP 1 are highly controversial among
sepsis experts they don't always match
the sepsis definition that we in the
laboratory and our EDS and ICUs are used
to using which is one of early
goal-directed therapy guidelines widely
used by the surviving sepsis campaign
and those bundles so I want to make it
clear that the sepsis bundles you're
sort of used to supporting from a
laboratory perspective or different than
the SEP 1 bundles in in several ways and
and so this is highly a contentious
process and you can read about the
surviving sepsis bundles in the
reference on the slide below the
critical care medicine and other
guidances that describe the surviving
sepsis campaign bundles so back to the
SEP 1 core measures all US hospitals and
emergency providers are accountable for
meeting the requirements of this measure
and the requirements is actually
adherence and documentation of each step
that is provided in the SEP 1 measure
now measures that are not yet included
include mortality and other clinical
outcomes but there is no guarantee that
these will not be added on as they
become more document in the literature
there's also no guarantee that
laboratory metrics revolving around
rapid reporting will not be someday
included in many of these guidelines as
we move forward so as sepsis becomes
more and more important from a human and
a financial and operational perspective
it's very important that the
laboratories prepare appropriately in a
proactive way now enforcement of the SEP
one of interesting in in its current
form it is
it is under the umbrella of what's
called a Hospital Compare scenario
so each hospitals adherence is reported
and then it's compared with other like
size hospitals for and severity matched
hospitals but the Joint Commission also
carries the risk of low scores or actual
non-compliance and the risk of losing
Joint Commission accreditation which is
we know is very important to our health
care organizations so that's sort of the
teeth of the SEP 1 core measure right
now but the door is opened and people
are alluding to the fact that future
value-based purchasing scenarios will be
added to the SEP 1 as it evolves and
this means that Medicare and Medicaid
reimbursement for sepsis cases would be
directly tied to your hospital's rate of
adherence to these core measures on a on
a kind of a population-based level but
also even to the granular level of a
case-by-case basis so that would mean if
a patient's case would qualify for that
measure the hospital's adherence would
determine whether or not that
organization would be reimbursed for
that entire bucket of sepsis care which
we all know is very expensive and so the
the teeth in this measure would be
enormous and the impact to our
organization's could potentially be
enormous and that is why we're talking
about them today so that we can
proactively be ready for whatever comes
our way
currently these measures are available
publicly on the website listed and so
there already is a current impact to
reputation in the local market place
wherever your Hospital is located and
these measures are very important to our
hospital leadership and as many people
have heard have heard me say if it's
important to them it should be important
to us
so the good news after all that bad news
perhaps is that there is a reprieve the
implementation of the step one is
delayed but not indefinitely step one
was scheduled to take effect in fiscal
year 2017 but after feedback from EDS
and physicians and hospitals CMS has
opted to delay but there still is a need
to prepare the laboratory for the
revised guideline now the bundle itself
the step one bundle relies on
recognition of what's called severe
inflammatory response syndrome or sirs
that means one that means a temperature
over 101 or a high or low temperature
heart rate greater than 90 respiratory
rate greater than 20 white cell count
greater than 12,000 per millimeter cubed
or less than 4000 and band emia now
you'll notice that the temperature can
be high or low and the white blood cell
count can be high or low
this is because when sirs hits a human
being it's because of the human beings
response towards the bacterial or fungal
or other pathogen antigens and what
becomes an anti a pro-inflammatory
response to up regulate the immune
system to react kind of over does it and
then there has to be an anti
inflammatory response to kind of get
people back in homeostasis so it's what
makes sepsis hard to recognize there
still is no national or international
agreed-upon definition of what sepsis is
as a global definition but we most
people do agree that sirs
is very close to what is listed here and
then for the step one bundle this is
what serves is defined as one in ten
patients admitted to an ICU in the
United States has or will develop severe
sepsis it involves about three percent
of all hospital discharges and the
incidence is increasing so
this is a really important focus for
microbiology labs around the globe now
the step one measured definitions are
listed here on the left from lowest to
highest severity sepsis is two of those
service criteria we just talked about
plus a suspected infection in them in
the eyes of a physician who's treating
that patient severe sepsis is lactate of
greater than two or or an organ
dysfunction septic shock was would be
severe sepsis with hypoperfusion despite
fluid boluses and a lactate greater than
four so we move from sepsis to septic
shock moves up on the severity scale but
I do want to caution that severe sepsis
is no longer a category and the
surviving sepsis guidelines which are
are the other definition and so that's
one of the measures that our difference
between SEP 1 with the SSC sepsis and
severe sepsis are barred together there
is no such thing as severe sepsis
anymore now what part does the
laboratory play well the step 1 measures
require an all-or-nothing approach to
the clock starting at the time of
presentation to the IDI for severe
sepsis and for septic shock and so
hospitals are required within 3 hours
for example to measure serum lactate
obtain blood cultures prior to
antibiotics and administer the of those
antibiotics prescribed by the
antimicrobial and infectious disease and
critical care teams this is where
microbiology comes in in the might in
the obtaining the blood cultures prior
to antimicrobials within six hours
repeats serum lactate if the initial
lactate is greater than two now this
might not seem like that hard to do but
there's a lot of other measures in this
I'm just giving you some examples there
are a few more items of
as well for the initial three hours and
six hour bundles for septic shock but
you get the picture we need to focus on
the blood cultures on our collaboration
with phlebotomy and our antimicrobial
stewardship teams so that leads to
reviewing ways that we can support
efforts to improve these core measures
and ultimately sexist outcomes now what
so what can we do at the local level
well in our place for the past several
years we've been auditing and mapping
process flow maps about how blood
cultures are ordered what order sets are
available in our hospital information
set Center how the sepsis bundle is
triggered and how physicians and nurses
are alerted how the order goes to
phlebotomy who collected and delivered
to the laboratory and each of these
timings is important to document and
align the timings of collection and
delivery and all of those things and we
found that through these audits we've
uncovered several issues that can impact
the core measure so this is just one
example when we looked at the timing of
blood culture collection in relationship
to antimicrobial administration we found
that we had several that were you know
seemed out of range kind of outliers and
when we investigated these we we learned
that the blood cultures for some reason
were ordered incorrectly or never
released properly into the laboratory
system and so when the laboratory
received them we had to cancel them and
reorder them properly when we did so the
later time period was the time that was
ported into the health information
system therefore it looked like all of
these blood cultures were collected way
after the time of antimicrobial
administration and therefore making our
numbers look poor when in fact they were
actually collected at the appropriate
time our 90th percentile for collection
one
the sepsis trigger is in places ranges
from you know one to three point six
minutes so it's a very finely tuned
system and it's because of us uncovering
these things that we can reliably say
that our numbers match when when the
audits occur it's also important to
document whether it's a phlebotomist
draw a nurse draw or even some places
are using paramedics so if if somebody
is being delivered by an ambulance the
drawing blood cultures there and and
cook the collection time then as always
before the antimicrobial delivery so
that's kind of a novel idea but and then
these metrics also pertain to when
you're looking at your blood culture
contamination which is also important
for the hospital quality metrics so
these are just some examples
I don't want anybody to assume that
because step one is delayed that it
won't happen or that it won't evolve
into other clinical mesh measures I it's
my opinion that laboratories should be
proactive in this we're already
supporting some surviving sepsis
campaign measures and it's my prediction
that the evidence-based guidelines that
show speed and diagnosis and and
microbial stewardship decisions are
useful and improve patient outcomes and
that some of them will eventually find
their way into these bundles whether
it's surviving sepsis or septic now is
our opportunity window to really get a
handle on what we're doing in terms of
blood cultures to support our
organizations and I would like to
propose that there are three three
common buckets I think for our strategy
surrounding actionable results that
might be related to diagnosis that could
be blended into these bundles in the
future and that any work you do to
support the timing the longitudinal
calculation of
each step of the way what happens to
that blood culture bottle from order to
the final result and delivery and
antimicrobials and delivery of a report
to a physician occur in these buckets
where diagnosis supports therapy
it supports outcome evaluation and and
diagnosis also supports the value that
our laboratory can provide to patients
and the value therefore that our
organization can provide so value is
kind of one of those terms like love you
know how do you define value in
healthcare it's a difficult strategy our
system takes a population health
strategy and value is sort of driven out
of its value for both the individual
patient and the greater population that
we serve so defining that value is
usually done by economists and there's a
very discipline measurement that uses
value towards improving processes
improving value and driving the system
forward values is defined as the health
outcomes achieved per dollar spent so
those outcomes can be many different
things and I'll be giving you examples
shortly but in our art place we look at
value as how what matters most to our
patients our payers our providers our
employees our suppliers and and value is
delivered that basically tries to unite
all of those special interests into one
composite reproducible and sustainable
process so the Krays the creation of
value for patients then should determine
the rewards for us in the system who are
good soldiers doing this and it is also
then sort of the premise of the SEP one
core measure that if you do better and
adhere to these guidelines your
outcomes will be better and so there you
should be financially rewarded for that
so there's a good reference I urge
people to read by Porter in the New
England Journal of Medicine called what
is value in health care and that
reference is provided for you it's a
it's a very interesting topic something
that we maybe take for granted but is
actually useful for us to document what
parts the laboratory plays and improving
value so where do you start if you
haven't taken this process already well
here's here's a tip about forming
strategic alliances that focus on
patient so we call these multiple
multidisciplinary stakeholder teams and
as you can see it ranges from emergency
medicine and critical care through
infectious disease pharmacy laboratory
nursing all the way through financial
systems coding economist nurse educators
lab educators our data analytics team
our court our C suite our Quality
Systems and in our information systems
and we have two things that I found to
be very important over over the lifetime
of these processes since I got here in
2013 and that is champions in each of
the categories I mean you have to find
you may not find somebody in each of
these buckets to play with you in the
sandbox or kind of move forward but
whoever is willing to participate
together you can make changes and that's
that's something that resonates with
people and they really buy into once
they kind of understand what the end
game is improving care for sepsis
patients the other thing that's
incredibly important is having a
historian for your larger team because
as the pie chart shows each of these
players unbeknownst to you is making
changes in their processes
moving forward and if you are not
collaborating with them and you're not
in the same sandbox then you have no
idea and so the last thing you want is
to go present oh we did this from the
laboratory point of view and this
improved mortality blah blah blah and
you're in front of the whole C suite and
they go oh well you know you know I see
you changed their protocol for XYZ at
the same time so how do you know this so
you really need to be dedicated to
keeping an organizational history for
what's going on around these core
measures because there the organization
is moving very fast improving everything
related to these when you are going to
assess your data or your information one
simple way I've found to document our
improved processes maybe faster time -
detection faster gram stain's faster
molecular identification is that value
equals quality plus service plus
outcomes over cost so if you have an
outcome you can use that it can be
outcomes over cost if you have a quality
practice or a quality improvement it can
be quality plus outcomes so any of those
top three value variables can be
bucketed together to kind of show here's
the improvement and here's what it cost
the laboratory in essence that's what
you're trying to say if I'm spending X X
$3,000 on something in the laboratory
but I've just saved you know that's my
cost but the the financial outcome was a
reduction of three million well my ratio
is looking pretty good so the this is
the kind of focus that I think people
need to be taking and the step two in
this is I urge everyone on the line to
collaborate with the national
initiatives there is an ongoing
initiative for evidence-based lab
medicine practice guidelines that
involves a
somatic review of the literature and
meta-analysis the first publication was
Clin micro reviews 2016 it was the first
ever evidence-based guidelines on
systematic review and meta-analysis to
be published the related links include
other evidence-based websites like the
agency for Healthcare Research and
quality the Cochrane Collaboration and
such and so read through this it's going
to sound like another language to you
when you're starting to read some of
these bio statistical terms and
definitions for evidence-based practice
but I guarantee you that it is the way
of the future and it is a way that
laboratories can pool their resources
the things I'm describing are not very
easy to do as a single site even to make
an improvement and then if you make an
improvement maybe it's not statistically
significant based on the number of
patients you've assessed but if you can
pull your data with the larger
laboratory community which is the
purpose of the the CDC ASM collaboration
you can be part of a national data
repository that maybe answer some of the
questions of what the laboratory can
contribute so I urge you all to read
this get involved this is this is
happening in its second round right now
and it and as you develop data there'll
be a national call for data to
contribute to the second round of this
analysis which focuses aren't those
wrapped more rapid laboratory
information actually impact downstream
variables like mortality costs and
things of that nature and what's what's
really unique about the EBL MGP evidence
guidelines we're all used to seeing
publications of primary and secondary
research they are largely biased towards
academic institutions that publish and
have huge research teams and things of
that nature but the EBL mpg
he allows unpublished work so even if
you only have 25 patients that you've
looked at that data can be pooled so
your in-house quality improvement
projects that may never get published
can still provide a national part of the
national guidance that then you can reap
benefit from now these EBL MPGs use a
Pico framework in which you must
describe your population your
intervention
what's your comparator method and what
outcomes are you looking for and I
referenced the price and Christensen
article in annals of Clinical
biochemists
this evl MGP process and the Pico
framework and also in the publication
that I noted from January 16 and Clin
micro reviews there's what we call a
study in a box so to speak the
appendices include data variables that
you might want to track in your
organization for quality improvement and
I know every time it comes around to the
calendar for what new quality
improvement projects you want to partake
take a look at this see if there's
something that you can add to your
quality improvement measures take one of
them off that's working fine and and try
to tackle something that might improve
your sepsis care so that that's there
for your use okay and and third we're
going to talk about examples of blood
culture mech metrics that you can use
I'll kind of elaborate on that study in
the box and give you some hardcore
examples and why they're important and
why controlling for them is important
now your typical blood culture measures
in microbiology you know we have a
couple of categories of best practice
things that we want most labs monitor
collecting two sets of blood cultures
prior to the administration of
antibiotics
your overall blood culture rates might
be monitored and based on the last clean
micronet survey and oh eight that we
took that the the median kind of was
around nine to 11 percent pause
the pathogen diversity is something that
you might want to monitor specifically
if you're comparing two periods of time
like the historic routine method and
maybe after introduction of a new
diagnostic because you don't you don't
want 20% e.coli in your historical
measure and 70% in coli in your
intervention measure that that will just
throw off your comparison so you want to
monitor those things people monitor the
proper blood volume collection from
adults 6 to 20 mils and also blood
culture contamination which is still
currently less than 3% but honestly
since chlorhexidine if you're not 1% or
less then you need to be making
improvements so these are all things
that we often measure in the laboratory
and this just gives you an example of
how you can show your impact without
knowing any statistics at all by just
doing graphs that show improvement over
time so this is a depiction of all of
our different system hospitals not the
last several are not included but when I
did this it showed our mothership on the
top and red which we were monitoring for
the longest and then as we added
hospitals to our system over time almost
every one of them started out either
above the line or with wide variations
if you move down towards you know the
green the blue the orange and then the
teal color and an overtime
implementation of standard phlebotomy
practices particularly in our emergency
rooms had everybody dropping towards you
know below 1% we do have outliers that
at the time of this graph have since
come in afterwards have come into
compliance when we've provided
phlebotomist for their emergency rooms
for example but it can show you how
history changes and how compliance the
standard guidelines can can drop things
here in the purple and then we finally
picked up
hospital that was as good as or better
than all of us with our our last
integration so it's really important to
sub stratify these keep a hospital the
hospital scorecard
because especially if you are going to
be trying to subtract to push laboratory
value as a part of these sepsis survival
guidelines and things of that nature you
need to have your background data in a
row and if you're introducing rapid
Diagnostics you certainly don't want to
be spending money testing what would be
only a blood culture contaminant but at
the time you may not know it so you want
to make sure your blood culture
contamination rate is exquisite lilo and
right now are always lower to our
measure to less than 2% but almost all
of our hospitals are less than 1% in our
the average for our GMC reference spaces
0.4 2.6 right now so it can be done it
takes a lot of people in an effort and a
system-wide delivery there is also an
evidence-based lab medicine practice
guideline that's published and is being
redone so if you're keeping these
metrics watch out for that call for data
as well with your quality improvement
projects other key strategic blood
culture monitors in microbiology that
people may not think of or the order to
collect time to collect to receive
receive to incubation your time to
detection or time to positivity collect
a result and a new one sort of emerging
is this time to actionable result the
time of the Gram stain the time of the
rapid diagnostic now not all of these
may be available to you many of them are
able to be identified out of the back
tech system and it but it will take a
combination of your lab information and
possibly your Hospital information
system and the back tech or whatever
other blood culture system you're using
to get all these time
in place and why is that important well
it's most important to have the order to
actionable result sort of first in the
pipeline and last out of the pack line
and and then the subsequent pharmacy
time but if you have outliers and you
can't pin down what part of the process
is being affected then you're going to
be at the mercy of all the changes of
the in-between variables so I urge you
all to look at this in our system we
discovered that for instance when we put
in the ground stain that time was
recorded it became organism 1g pcs and
clusters let's say then when we knew it
was staph aureus the next day and we put
that result in we lost the time of the
Gram stain and we could never get it
back no matter how much we begged or
offered to pay our laboratory
information system so not all lis s are
created equal and we are you know since
fixing that we do data dumps to grab
that information before it gets
overwritten but that's kind of an
important piece one was the Gram stain
there what pharmacy action was taken
based on the ground stain and then let's
say have a molecular method well that
came afterward and then what happened
with the pharmacy or the prescription
you need to be able to identify all
those time periods
other examples of operational metrics
that you might look at the bed days or
length of stay with that one I'll
caution you if you're looking at
mortality and length of stay if you
improve your mortality
sometimes your length of stay will go up
and you need to understand that dead
people have no length of stay they're
gone and the more people you save the
more people will be in your Hospital so
don't let a finance or an operational
person say well yeah that's fine but
your length of stay went up your length
of stay will go up your ICU days
likewise sometimes your vent days there
are things called inpatient length of
stay ratios
where you get your system wherever you
at you're at will have an observed to
expected ratio our vendor is premier and
there are five or six national vendors
that deliver this kind of length of stay
that's morbidity matched and they're the
book that describes how the numbers are
defined is about six inches tall so I
don't I can't explain that to you per se
but every hospital has them this is the
first place I look the o2 II mortality
metrics and the OD e length of stay
ratios that your quality office will
have so reach out to them get access to
them as you make changes in the
laboratory you may see changes that are
developing in these ratios recovered
cost laboratory cost a longitudinal
metrics satisfaction scores at set or a
decreased number of readmissions these
are all things that you can look at as
far as proving the laboratory value or
impact on these operational metrics
antimicrobial stewardship metrics could
include defined daily doses antibiotic
cost of stay for example antibiotic
length of stay appropriate use of
antibiotics time to targeted therapy
your resistance rates are harder to
budge in terms of your antibiotic remote
over time they may budge and so here
this listing kind of just gives you
another opportunity to look at different
metrics and these are all generally
reported in events per thousand bed days
per the antimicrobial stewardship
program metrics now clinical metrics
again I refer back to these premiere or
other vendor observe to expected metrics
you will you should have an observed to
expect it for your 30 day 90 day 120 all
cause you should get your ms-drg for
sepsis or severe sepsis in that
information and you want to relate that
to your time to diagnosis your time to
treatment
maybe you want to look at adverse drug
reactions in your population or
infection related mortality now the last
thing we want to talk about our metrics
that can be used as a control for bias
of your experiment these are things that
are harder to get for instance
though if you are reporting to a large
your upper level quality folks you want
to be able to make sure you're telling
them that the sepsis severity the ms-drg
eight seventy eight seventy one and
eight seventy two are similarly matched
in your pre intervention in your post
intervention cohorts so that is your
historical versus your you know after
the new method or the new blood culture
instrument kind of data was the
compliance with the sepsis bundle
similar was the primary diagnosis
similar how about age gender weight
height ratios these are things that can
be extracted or obtained proactively
with an appropriate IRB for human
subjects or or without if you're just
doing a quality project are the hospital
services that are treating these
patients similar this is all important
things that can skew your results if you
don't know that these things are
maintained at a solid level while the
other other data variables are changing
do you have an enriched data set you
know your ICU patients are going to have
a higher proportion of positives than
your general patients is the order to
collect blood culture time consistence
this is one of the reasons why we keep
that metric blood culture contamination
volume and all the other things we
talked about and is your data management
system even the same during during your
period of inter of assessments your
sepsis coding practices during the time
that you're collecting data must remain
uniform just cross that [ __ ] out and say
must there's an impact to how people
code sets us because of there's no
international defined guidelines so at
least in your organization
how'd sepsis is defined and coded should
remain you
former that will completely skew your
data the percentage of the bundle
compliance and all of these other things
that we did talk about our own non
laboratory conditions and those require
external data dumps from places within
your organization this is an example for
us when we standardize coding so the red
arrow all of those phases of improvement
were during a standard coding system but
look at the difference in our sepsis
ratios actually this is raw mortality of
severe sepsis when we change the coding
there's no way you could include the
blue bar on the left in the rest of your
decision-making because it altered it so
much and this is true across every
organization I've ever spoken with it
does sepsis research so this is really
important item I want to stress it
another thing that happens is as here's
an example of the total sepsis alerts
called in re D since we that now
recently improved the sepsis alert
system if you're a laboratory and you do
not want to be collecting information at
the time of this high variability you
either want to get your data for your
lab interventions before all this
variability or wait till it increases
and then flatlines kind of stabilizes
itself because these kind of severe
seismic shifts are all reasons that your
data would be skewed so you this is
where the historian in your organization
becomes very important who's switching
what would sepsis and you know letting
everyone else know that something is
happening so luckily we knew this was
happening and we're not doing any
interventions at the moment and then
finally I want to close with some simple
statistics that support the measurement
of your quality and the comparison of
your quality metrics around blood
culture so these examples are going to
be from when we introduced the back tech
Mabini back tech FS six system and the
plus aerobic s and lytic ten anaerobic s
media into our organization and the
other thing that I'll mention really
quickly is that some of the statistics
here may be unfamiliar to you don't
don't get intimidated this this
publication right here statistics for
method verification is a good reference
to get started with or by yourself a
biostatistics book even though this is
focused on method verification it's
going to also give you some insight into
how to calculate your means and your
medians how to create histograms what's
a data distribution how to choose what
statistics to use dependent on your data
distribution and other things about
general experimental design so I wrote
that as a reference for folks and I hope
it it's helpful for you several people
have have reached out and said it's
helpful so I even though it's not
related to blood cultures I'm still kind
of giving you the reference so you can
start reading into that the first place
I start when I'm looking at whether
we're seeing effects is a simple eyeball
of data you know I just eyeball this
data over time and and this actually
depicts what happened with our back tech
implementation with our mortality our
actual or observed to expected ratio
over this time period was reduced by
about 40 percent and it was
statistically significant but I didn't
know that at the beginning what I had
was baseline data and then we had our
first sepsis educational six month
period in 2013 we then proceeded to let
a waiting period occur because to kind
of hardwire the effects of the education
and then by chance we were granted money
for the back tech system and
lo and behold the implementation of the
back tech in the ICU around May of 2014
substantially lowered and limited
variability in our observed to expected
ratios and then we went live later with
all of our inpatients and we saw another
decrease so after I saw this trend and
you don't need to be a biostatistician
to see this trend all you need to do is
is have a bar chart and a calendar and
and Buckett your categories then you go
into each of the buckets you know kind
of starting with our our wait time where
which the education was performed and
and the hardwiring was taking place and
not statistically different from each
other but looking at the changes in the
back tech versus this historical
information and then taking those data
points and doing statistical comparisons
and graphs based on the buckets of
information you have from the trend line
the other thing that you can do without
much statistics is just simply look at
your phenomics and eyeball them what's
your most common and most deadly blood
culture infections and in this case we
looked at a reduction in turnaround time
for our back tech cohort back tech be
here in underline we saw reductions in
many of the turnaround times that also
you know gave you wouldn't you would not
be able to claim that the lab had any
impact to the mortality unless you had
this associated laboratory data so this
is the second place to look into your
phenomics and in fact we saw 50%
reduction in turnaround time in our
early pilot data now the next thing I
want to describe is the standard error
of the mean that's the average deviation
of the mean as it relates to the sample
size what you normally see depicted in
laboratory or other publications as a
standard deviation but because of the
way sepsis because of the way the
laboratory has to do research I mean we
kind of have to take what we
if if we had been given the capital for
backtick any sooner than we did we can't
control when we get that money and we
can't delay it based on wanting to
compare values so you kind of have to
take what you get and you're your pre
and post intervention periods don't
always have the same number of data
points so the sample size is different
and this is where the standard error of
the mean can help you may have outliers
in some of your patients in a sepsis
data set and if you show the standard
deviation that'll be highly skewed by
these outliers so when you're presenting
graphs to go to financer or build your
business case for new diagnostics and
it's important to know that if you have
these either outliers or different
sample sizes the standard error of the
mean may be a better metric to use and
it is very similar to the standard
deviation looking at the normal kind of
bell curve of your results and looking
at the top and bottom 2.5% of the
outliers of your metrics and it's also
important to know that whenever you use
confidence intervals as a statistic so
say you have a mortality ratio in the
pre intervention and a mortality ratio
and which is the average of your post
intervention you're going to want to put
a level of variability around it which
is a 95% confidence interval this is
based on the standard error of the mean
again pointing out that 2.5% extreme
variance and proving that you have
statistical significance if you're 95
percent confidence intervals do not
overlap that's a measure that you're 95%
sure that the true population of your
different means is you know is actually
different that they're not overlapping
this assumes a normal random sample a
normal bell curve of data and if you
don't have a normal bell curve of the
the data that you have in your when you
graph your results then you kind of have
to
use different statistics and for the
most part you will be using
nonparametric statistics because of the
outliers and the differences the way
sepsis is analyzed but the 95%
confidence interval is always a good bet
and most most excel and statistical
programs give you this very easily it's
very easy to compare if they overlap
they're not statistically different if
they don't overlap they are
statistically different this is an
example of the mean change in cohort B
we have the implementation of the back
Tec this was a reduced length of stay
that we saw standard errors of the beans
are pictured as our error bar and this
is just a simple graph of the quality
experimental design of pre and post
intervention with cohort B the
implementation of the back Tec this is a
graph of several levels of intervention
and it is here to depict the fact that
I'm going to go back one slide the
wilcoxon rank-sum is is a statistic that
you will use for nonparametric
comparison of these two groups but if
you have more than two groups as in this
case you're going to become using what's
called a kruskal-wallis statistic and
and here you can see that the median
drops off nicely but you see the
variability of the mean when you compare
your means to your medians your means
are the averages your medians are the
point at which 50% of your data lies
above the median and below the median
your mean is skewed when you have
outliers so when you see when you make
bar graphs in Excel and you see this
kind of wide difference between the dark
blue and the dark blue the median the
the lighter teal and the teal of the
median you know you have outliers and
that is a tip-off that you need to be
using nonparametric
statistics this is no time for a t-test
a t-test is for bell shaped data and so
when you have that big of a difference
you're normally distributed data in
which you can use a t-test your mean
will be very close if not equivalent to
your median so that's that's how you can
tell which statistic to use and again
this is a crux of all X analysis of
direct costs the last thing you can do
without heavy duty statistics is just a
simple sub stratification and in this
case we've looked we've chosen to sub
stratify by the most severe sepsis case
cases and look at survivors and
fatalities before and after the BAC text
so on the right you have the proportion
of fatalities in the BAC Tech is much
less than the fatalities in gray in this
then sorry you have much fewer
fatalities in cohort B and the gray than
you do in the fatality bucket 8 of 8 in
1 in cohort a and likewise your
survivors are opposite then you have
more survivors in the grey for the BAC
tech intervention and fewer 4 for the
other blood culture system so this is
this is done to kind of give you a
visual effect to double-check your
numbers it's also done because not all
of your populations may see the same
drastic change in general we see the
sicker the patients are the more that
speed helps them survive and and to that
end if someone's not that very thick and
it's a community-acquired case some of
those folks get better even if they
don't get antibiotics from from a
bacteremia so you really kind of have to
define your population and I usually
start out looking at the most severe
group because if I can't make a change
in the most severe group you know maybe
I can make a change in the less severe
group but it's certainly a good place to
start it
always serve me well to look at them
first and then finally even simple
descriptive statistics are important to
do so here's a display of the different
services that treated a sepsis cohort
that we were looking at and between
cohort a and cohort B now you could see
that orthopedic surgery and OBGYN had
none none in cohort a well if if they
account for 90 percent of your patients
then you're in trouble but if there's
only one case from each of these then
you can kind of determine that when the
biostatisticians get the results that
you're you you may need their help in
normalizing for changes in service it's
what really not going to impact so much
and it's worth going forward if you look
at these buckets like Family Practice
let's say where there's none of those in
cohort B and that accounts for 75% of
your patients you would have a problem
but if you have kind of an equal
distribution of green and blue and your
two cohorts among the services and if
you know that your critical care
services it could counts for in our
sense something like eighty percent and
they're a direct match down three from
the bottom well then you know that okay
this datasets coming along let's let's
do the the multivariate regression and
things that maybe the people in the
laboratory wouldn't do but a
biostatistician can do it's kind of a
gut check to make pie charts for graphs
of this nature histogram like graphs
that can easily let you look at the
proportions of what you have so those
are some simple tips for biostatistics
and in review the step one core measures
are not yet finalized but they probably
will be in our future I advise to
prepare for step one core measures now
and continue to support surviving sepsis
campaign I advise fine-tuning all of
your blood culture processes from all
phases pre-analytical analytical post
analytical and getting that to the
highest measure so that when the time
comes
you've got best practices in your
laboratory and that will do nothing but
help the rest of the organization
document the laboratory impact of your
blood culture interventions and
practices with your new instruments or
rapid technology and do think about
participating in the evidence-based lab
medicine practice guidelines and expand
the way you analyze your data for your
quality measures when you're you know a
trend graph is nice but but it's not too
hard to learn or Google or YouTube how
to do a wilcoxon rank-sum in Excel I
mean all these things are online and
they're pretty easy to do and chances
are your organization has some kind of
bio statistical package we use jump JMP
and that's you know I'm not a
statistician but it serves me very well
and then reach out to biostatisticians
economists and others the data analytics
people who can pull the data you need to
fill in the gaps for your laboratory
care so I want to thank you very much
for your kind attention and patience
with the technical difficulties
experienced at the source and shout out
to my guy singer microbiology colleagues
and white center for research colleagues
who I am honored to work with every day
take any questions that you may have
thank you very much thank you so much
dr. work for your informative
presentation and for your important
research we will now start the live Q&A
portion of this webinar again if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that
green Q&A button at the lower left of
your presentation window type that
question into the box that appears on
the screen and click the send button
will answer as many questions as we have
time for so let's get started with our
first questions we have a very
captivating audience today dr. Wolk
what about emerging new diagnostics of
sepsis are they complementary to blood
culture and the sepsis core measures and
how often the court are the core
measures get getting revised and up
with improved technic techniques and
technology sort of a three-part question
there yeah yeah no worries I you you're
spot-on Carolina from Rutgers they are
complement rapid deck Diagnostics are
complementary to blood cultures as a
sidebar they are not yet included in the
sepsis core measures it's in terms of
rapid Diagnostics the only thing that's
included in the SEP one is that percent
of blood cultures collected before
antibiotics so if the focus is just step
one and that comes to fruition then the
only thing will be you know order to
collect collect two antibiotic delivery
and those time points being captured so
that's the first place to start
now the surviving sepsis bundles and
sort of these premiere observe to
expected mortality bundles that's that
they to surviving sepsis campaign only
talks about blood cultures being
collected before antibiotics they the
authors document that it's a limitation
that in terms of microbiology I'm sorry
because they include lactate and other
chemistry and white blood cell counts
and things but in terms of microbiology
even the surviving sepsis campaign notes
that it's a limitation that they don't
have one laboratory on on their their
panel it's the third or fourth iteration
of the SSC guidelines and there's still
no laboratory and on there I wish they
would ask me but they haven't yet and
they probably won't but so that's the
thing now I can't answer how the SEP one
core measures how often they will be
revised because they're delayed and
they're not even issued yet but I can't
answer that the surviving sepsis
campaign guidelines get revised every
two to four years and in terms of the
microbiology the American Society of
microbiology and the CDC evidence-based
medicine practice go
lines they are based on a standard that
gets where the literature gets looked at
every three to five years they must be
updated the literature must be updated
the statistics analysis of all the
composite data so that that occurs you
know in the case of blood cultures the
first cycle it you know was published in
2016
we're already redoing them because of
the number of publications on rapid
Diagnostics that occurred between you
know 2013-14 and so we're already
redoing those and you should watch for
those to be coming out so it depends on
what measure it is and the step one
- put out that that laboratory or other
clinical outcome measures will be
included but I do encourage everybody to
get involved in their sepsis teams
because if you're not you're not you're
not at the table then you're on the menu
so you know the lab doesn't get the the
input and they don't get to be part of
the team and that's always bad for the
laboratory I hope that answers your
questions thank you doctor look we have
another great question coming in from
our audience member we are creating our
blood culture and monitors what is the
recommended lobotomy response from
orders to collecting the blood culture
is it 30 minutes is it one hour hi Jim
how you doing out there in Louisville
good question that the the set one core
measures demand Anna microbials be
delivered in three hours that that's a
really long time period from
presentation but that it you know it's a
big window to hit so and I'm not aware I
did check with phlebotomy if they had
any national board certified
phlebotomist for this they do not they
have guidelines on how to collect
but not necessarily on when to collect
in our system like I said 90 we are
monitoring our system and just forcibly
improving that 90% of all our blood
cultures are collected within three
point six minutes of the order in epoch
so we fine-tuned it down to the point
where we can hardly fine-tune it anymore
but certainly I think you know with
within a 15 half an hour window would
give them plenty of time to - you know
most places can't get the antibiotics to
people that quickly our system is pretty
fine-tuned so and the window is three
hours right now they may ratchet that
down in the future thanks for you thank
you so much thank you so much
can thank you audience members for your
wonderful questions today that the work
will be emailing all further questions
coming in and giving those responses to
audience members I'd like to also today
think again BBD diagnostic systems for
sponsoring this important webinar and
laborat for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through March 2018 you'll receive an
email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
and thanks for joining us we hope to see
you again soon
bye bye everyone